so the EU is negotiating a new trade and
investment agreement with the u.s. it's
a big deal in many ways and yet it
affects you that's the whole idea the
transatlantic trade and investment
partnership or TTIP would boost growth
and create jobs across the EU
partnerships like relationships take
time and great care to work out and we
have more to consider than dating
etiquette
hear your voice matters however loud or
quiet and we take every concern
seriously elected governments and
politicians are closely involved and
we're working hard to keep everyone with
a stake in t tip well informed we want
your input and for you to have all the
facts so you can make up your own mind
we're listening we do get it learn more
about t tip and have your say
you